the opponent has to sacrifice on G7 and  will be stalemate I mean Perpetual  checkpoint on me but that's it now King  E7 wins the game for Magnus  has Magnus won all his three games today  yeah well I'm I'm not only today he  finally has the feeling like he has  almost won all his games he's won all  his games the ones that he's played  unreal stuff G5 well this was a big Miss  by uh Vincent as you're pointing out  people Peter maybe we can just have that  position on the board where the  evaluation of the game completely  changed that moment from  uh slipping out from a draw to a lost  position Queen H2 would be threatening  Queen H4 Queen H5 and queen H3 not Queen  H4 and uh with nothing better to do  Magnus would have to take Rook takes G7  King G7 and force the draw with Queen E7  Queen E8 uh perpet